[Music]
i love that you took some well-deserved
time off i knew like i needed that
summer i needed it with my kids needed
it like we just needed a minute and so
um it was the most wonderful time ever
spent it was hard to leave i had several
questions in my soul going why am i
leaving
you feel more balanced now i don't know
if balance is the word we should be
using because it's never going to be
perfectly balanced right because life
evan you know everything ebbs and flows
kelly's back from montana rested and
whooping it up on the cover of variety
the article asking can kelly clarkson
save daytime yup it's a wild time for
talk shows ellen dr oz and wendy
williams are all off the air and if you
think there's a rivalry brewing between
these two think again another american
idol alum jennifer hudson is doing big
things with their own talk show too have
you been able to share some words of
wisdom for her i don't feel like she
needs words of wisdom because she's
awesome but i definitely texted her i
was like oh my gosh so it's a whole
different world from like music but like
if you ever need anything like let me
know it's just exciting to see and shari
shepard i'm excited for as well she's
taking over wendy williams and i'm a big
fan of hers we love her here there's
room for all of us and and we're only
going to lift everyone up how do you
feel heading into the fourth round of
the kelly clarkson show i feel like you
know we're at this point where it's now
people know us you know like people are
you know people have always known you
kelly well i mean but they know but not
everyone but like i just mean like
they're starting to get to know the show
right
[Music]
even the kalioke's people are starting
to get to know better so we're actually
having people
like celebrities be like hey and also if
she wanted to do something with the
kalyoke i'd be interested and it's like
wait what so it's it it's just turning
into like an even cooler thing we're
talking about some words of wisdom do
you have any for miss camila cabello as
she takes on her red chair uh near mr
shelton yeah you and gwen would make a
great team what the i want the best for
him no you don't you want the worst for
me both can be true good luck with that
bring a shield i think she's going to do
well and i hope she kicks his ass
i think she has a good chance i will say
though we will miss you this season oh
thank you it was bittersweet doing the
press without you this year but i'm so
happy for you of someone from the
outside who's always been like how in
the heck are you doing all of these
things yeah i'm so glad you were able to
take a step back you know spend that
quality time with your family
kelly kicks off season four of her talk
show with garth brooks on monday i think
people are finally where they belong and
that's together again
and she just celebrated a major
milestone
kelly
20 years ago this past sunday nearly 23
million people tuned in to watch her
become the first american idol champ it
was a very emotional day and i just you
know had just been weeping all day for a
different reason and then all of a
sudden it hit me i was like oh my god
it's september 4th it's crazy there's no
there are no words to describe how
fortunate you feel